l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur jean charles
taugourdeau monsieur le premier ministre
dans quelques minutes va nous être
soumis le vote de la rectification du
budget de la france
un cadeau de noël s'y cache l'annulation
du redressement fiscal de mediapart qui
a une dette envers le trésor public
depuis juin 2009 pourquoi simplement
parce que mediapart mediapart s'est
auto-attribué depuis cinq ans un taux de
tva très très réduit de 2,1 pour cent
réservée à la presse imprimée
monsieur le premier ministre quel
message envoyé vous aux entrepreneurs
aux artisans aux commerçants aux
agriculteurs aux professions libérales
qui subissent redressement et même refus
de crédit d'impôt qui doivent rembourser
les trop-perçus monsieur le premier
ministre quel message envoyé vous aux
familles auxquelles on demande de
rembourser les trop-perçus dette sociale
même plusieurs années après les faits
vous aimez assurément la presse monsieur
le premier ministre vous nous avait déjà
fait le coup avec le journal l'humanité
il ya deux ans un trou de 4 millions
d'euros
rebouchez en 30 secondes ici même sur le
compte de la liberté de la presse est là
encore là encore des députés socialistes
de votre majorité vote en catimini un
amendement pour annuler le redressement
fiscal de mediapart et lui faire un
cadeau de noël de 4 millions 100 mille
euros de fraude fiscale
vous allez me dire veut que votre
ministre du budget s'y est opposée c'est
vrai mais mais ils l'ont voté avec votre
rapporteur général du budget alors ma
question est simple monsieur le premier
ministre
quand je pense à moi président qui
voulait une république exemplaire
pensez-vous être encore crédibles en
matière de justice sociale et justice
fiscale
votre réponse intéresse tous les
contribuables justiciables de francs
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
mme adam a mis sur la culture
s'il vous plaît merci madame la
présidente monsieur le député vous
interroger sur un amendement voté par
les députés sur le cas de mediapart
voudrais d'abord revenir sur un ensemble
de mesures que nous avons prises au sein
du gouvernement pour soutenir la presse
parce que je crois que les événements
récents
les événements récents nous ont montré à
quel point la liberté d'expression et la
liberté de la presse étaient des valeurs
auxquelles la république était apte à
lille vous plaît et devait réaffirmer
son soutien de manière massive en est la
raison pour laquelle la raison pour
laquelle nous avons l'année dernière
entamé une réforme à laquelle nous nous
étions engagés de soutien au pluralisme
de la presse pour soutenir les
hebdomadaires et les périodiques ayant
une mensualité autres quotidienne pour
qu'ils puissent également bénéficier des
dents bénéficiant jusqu'à présent au
quotidien à faibles ressources
publicitaires c'est une réforme dont
nous sommes fiers et qui a été voté par
les députés ici pour se tenir des
quotidiens et des périodiques qui font
vivre le débat démocratique dans notre
pays
maintenant vous parler de la presse en
ligne et de la tva applicable à la
presse en ligne
vous savez très bien que ce gouvernement
a également pris une loi afin d'aligner
le taux de la tva sur la presse en ligne
sur celle de la presse papier et c'est
une position que nous avons constamment
défendu au sein les instances
communautaires parce que nous
considérons qu'elle est conforme à la
convergence qui existe aujourd'hui entre
les différentes instances de presse et
nous continuons à défendre cette
position et nous continuerons à le faire
au sein de la commission européenne la
loi est la loi nous considérons qu'elle
doit s'appliquer
en attendant en attendant et tant que
les modifications n'ont pas été
entérinés par la commission européenne
et c'est la position qu'a défendu le
gouvernement lors de la discussion de
cet amendement de consignes nous
considérons que la loi doit s'appliquer
nous considérons que nous devons
appliquer le même taux de tva à la
presse en ligne
mais tant que cette décision n'a pas été
validé par les autorités communautaires
et bien nous considérons que la loi doit
s'appliquer
merci madame la mini